at least we have competent people in
charge that's the thing uh these are
good people these are wise people and uh
if they just had more of our money and
more of our attention and more power
over us they'd be doing more good stuff
wouldn't they no uh here is kate
bettingfield this is gen jensaki light
she is the white house press secretary i
guess saki was in a depression yesterday
couldn't show up to the press conference
so kate bettingfield checked in and she
was asked about our crazy spending and
her answer is quite curious
how after printing trillions of dollars
taxpayers might want to know is there
not enough money to continue fighting
the pandemic trillions of dollars
you're out of it is all the accounting
done every single dollar so we have the
resources that we need in this current
moment what we need is this funding to
be able to plan for the future to
prepare for uh for as i say the
possibility of a new variant the
possibility of a new wave we don't want
to be caught flat-footed
what was that kate uh first off kate
looks like she's in 10th grade i don't
know where they're getting these people
but i mean she looks like she's 16 or
something um we need more money and more
bigger budgets so that we can prepare
for the future and the next wave of
kovid ah
that's interesting a little hint perhaps
a little dropping of a crumb to tell us
that kovid may be coming back could that
be uh she continued though uh talking
about whether uh kovid's coming back and
what taxpayers are going to think of it
in the whole shebang go
for taxpayers would be skeptical i mean
trillions of dollars and obviously
billions more i think taxpayers want to
be prepared for the virus and they want
to make sure that we have the resources
that we need to keep them safe and
that's what this administration is
focused on
taxpayers want to be prepared for the
virus yes yes if only you guys had more
of our money we could be more prepared
for the virus that you failed miserably
at stopping
i don't like these people i don't like
them very much
but they're telling us right this is
what i'm talking about the crumbs
they're being dropped they're telling us
we need more of your money why do we
need more of your money well we always
need more of your money i mean
you know we're not very good with money
we don't really know anything about
inflation or budgets we forget to carry
the one et cetera et cetera if we just
had more your money we could protect you
from kovit because we've done so well at
it and even though we're having a little
lull in copied right now for the new
season of war over in eastern europe
they're obviously telling us that covet
is coming back here's biden pushing for
monoclonal treatments
the same monoclonal treatments that he
stopped florida from doing because they
were doing it for a year and then he
forced the federal government to move on
the states and stop them from doing it
the monoclonal antibodies take
monoclonal item bodies for example
they've helped save lives this isn't
partisan it's medicine
but congress hasn't provided enough
money to keep purchasing these
monoclonal by
anybody
it's not partisan it's medicine great
line okay who wrote that um
he literally did that the federal
government moved on florida to stop
florida from using monoclonal treatment
as some of you may remember right when
we got down here to florida in december
a little bit before christmas that's
when omicron was going crazy david and i
both got uh kovid and we immediately
within the hour got monoclonal treatment
here in florida i then was sick for
about three days i had leg aches that's
it david actually was a little bit more
sick we're both unvaccinated that was
our own personal choice but obviously
we're fine now but the point is that the
administration which was railing against
monoclonal treatment which was
completely pushing for vaccine mandates
even as the evidence was coming out that
the vaccines were not working as
promised now it's about monoclonal
treatment and if he just had more money
from congress which means your money
then we would have more of the treatment
that he didn't want people getting a few
months ago
you